hey have you really really really
screwed up with money have you ever
bought something woke up the next
morning and looked in the mirror and
thought I'm looking at an idiot I have
have you ever bought something and you
can't even remember what you paid for it
because you're so impulse tit I have
have you ever bought something and hid
it from your spouse because you were
such a chicken that you couldn't I was a
bad chicken did you hear that chicken
that was a really bad chicken you didn't
give me a sound effect James child I'll
cue that ah yeah just work on that stuff
because obviously I don't do chicken
well but out of your chicken bra is that
that's a chicken there we go Rock mark
there we go
alright that's better I don't know where
I got that other one but uh are you such
a chicken that you don't tell your
spouse because you're in such disconnect
on money what you did with money yeah
we've been there man when we were losing
everything I couldn't hardly look my
wife in the face cuz I the poor woman
thought she married Sir Galahad turns
out it was goober it was awful she was
afraid and I felt like an idiot
that is a bad chemistry right there when
someone's afraid meet someone that feels
like that feels like their self-esteem
is plummeting and that person meets
someone that's afraid this isn't this is
combustible activity right here this is
why money problems are the number one
caused a divorce in North America today
money fights are the number one cause a
divorce and North America today if
that's you if you have
lived without a budget you have nothing
saved for retirement you've got a
student loan that's been around so long
you think it's a pet MasterCard is your
master you have American distress if
that's you if you've got car payments
that look just there sitting in the
driveway looking at you yelling in there
saying you're stupid
when you walk out to your car your car
looks at you and says you're stupid you
have a $600 car payment you're stupid if
your car says that to you you know what
you're normal in America normal drive
down your street count ten houses one
two you can see when your mind right now
can't you think about ten of your houses
in your neighborhood
one two three four five six seven eight
nine see em ten seven of them are living
paycheck to paycheck they have no money
all the money comes in all the money
goes out there one job layoff from
foreclosure and repossession they are
one major medical event or car wreck
away from a huge probably bankrupt able
financial crisis but they look good
there's a bass boat in the driveway two
nice cars in front of a house that
really shouldn't have all of this stuff
in front of it it's a decent house but
come on I mean sometimes you drive down
through these neighborhoods and you're
going you people spend all your money on
your cars obviously not on your house
ever look at that this is normal seven
out of ten houses not me Dave I live in
a nice neighborhood I know in that
neighborhood it's eight out of ten
because they're all about big hat no
cattle it's all about how it looks and
press somebody to stoplight you'll never
meet that's normal normal is all the
money comes in all the money goes out
only the names are changed to protect
the innocent I retire with social
insecurity because my entire life I've
had too much month left at the end of
the money because I don't have a plan
and I can't control the person in my
mirror that's normal I've been there let
me just help you with this in case you
hadn't said it out loud
since I was there and I've got a PhD and
stupid I know what it looks like I've
got a PhD in D um B that's what
qualifies me to do this show I've done
every possible thing wrong but I quit
let me help you with this
I remember normal it was a long time ago
I still remember the fear creeping from
my stomach up into my throat
I still remember sitting down to do the
checkbook and there's that sweat on the
upper lip because I'm an overdraft again
still remember that sense of being a
failure but it was all behind closed
doors the bushes are trimmed out front
the car is shiny sitting in the driveway
it was a picture that looked good but it
was a facade it was fake it was like
when we visited Universal Studios a few
years ago and we got to go on the movie
lot and we walked down the street of
this beautiful homes that were built for
the camera only they weren't really
houses they were just the Front's of
houses so when you went through the back
door there was nothing there
or the front door it was all for the
camera lens people live their lives all
for the camera lens all what other
people see for the optics of what your
friends and your neighbors and your
relatives see that it gives the
appearance of being successful and the
dirty little secret is normal it's broke
in America if you're normal you're broke
making eighty thousand dollars of your
household income in your freaking broke
that's normal normal sucks you don't
want to be normal so when you call this
show and you're doing something smart
and I say how weird you are you're
awesome you're weird that's one of the
biggest compliments you can get because
you don't want to be normal you want to
be weird normals in a desperate
situation and the denial is so huge
because there's this tremendous amount
of financial emotional and spiritual
even relational energy being spent to
create a the optics the look of success
when there's not any real success
because you're making a lot of money you
have nothing nothing your plan for
retirement is hoping a government which
is well known for its ability to handle
money is going to take care of you
that's just plain stupid and all of us
have done it man it is time to stop
America it we are so past time for a
renaissance in the art of personal
finance that it is unbelievable you're
do you're do to start winning and you
know one of the biggest things that
requires the the biggest blocker the
biggest one of the biggest things you
have to break through to start winning
with money is you have to stop caring
what other people think you have to
suddenly go you know mom I don't care if
you don't like it that I'm not going on
vacation I'm broke and we're getting out
of this mess you know my friend I'd love
to go out to dinner with you but we are
broke and we are getting out of this
mess yeah yeah no I person to the
stoplight looking at my old car you can
just look at my old car I am driving it
with pride baby because I'm getting out
of that I'm getting out of debt so that
I can use my most powerful wealth
building tool which is my income to
build wealth and live the life I want to
live and Drive what I want to drive and
be outrageously generous in the process
but you can't be outrageously generous
or live the life you want to live when
all you're doing is spending your money
trying to give the appearance
of success when in reality you're an
abject failure at what you're doing and
yeah I'm talking to you you look good
and you're a little bit arrogant about
it some of you a little bit prideful you
throw your shoulders back and talk about
how wise you are to use your credit
cards for airline miles and I think to
myself there's another [ __ ] because
I've been that [ __ ] I know what a [ __ ]
looks like I've looked at him in the
mirror it's time to stop it's time to
stop and change directions right now
that is what this show is about it's
about helping you get on a path that
causes you to really win not just fight
and scrap to give the optics to give the
look of winning when in reality normal
sucks and you're just normal
don't be normal anymore today is the day
to turn towards weirdness this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a five hundred
thousand dollar income